[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the American flag has endured in its
many forms as the ultimate symbol of
freedom justice and the American Way but
did you know that our nation's flag was
designed by a high school student from
Ohio according to legend the original
American flag from 1776 was sown by a
lady named Betsy Ross it had 13 stars in
a circle representing America's original
13 States as more states join the Union
people kept adding more stars to the
flag
so by 1958 the US flag had a total of 48
stars for the 48 states of that time
which brings us to our high school
student Robert heft Roberts history
teacher gave his students and open-ended
assignment make a project illustrating
your interest in American history
it could be anything so Robert who was
jazzed about hearing that Alaska and
Hawaii were going to become States cut
up an old 48 state flag in his
grandparents basement and designed his
own vision for a 50 state flag when he
turned in his final assignment Roberts
teacher said anyone can make a flag and
it's got the wrong number of stars the
grade came back Abby - Robert tried to
explain his idea to his teacher who
replied I'll change your gray when your
flag is accepted by the US Congress game
on Robert wrote 21 letters and called
the White House 18 times until one day
in 1960 Roberts phone rang
[Music]
hello hello Robert hell it was President
Eisenhower with news that Roberts
50-state flag design had actually been
chosen as the new official flag of the
United States the president invited
Roberts Washington where he saw his
American flag fly for the first time on
July 4th nineteen sixty cents then
Roberts 50 state flag has remained
unmatched is the quintessential symbol
of America but I know what you're
thinking whatever happened to that B -
Roberts teacher honored his promise and
changed the grade to an A
[Music]
our founding fathers were booze hounds
so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed especially since water wasn't
always clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington racked up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just 54 delegates
zone me and John Adams went on a
seven-week binge drinking 6 hours a
night with younger congressmen keep
drinking so Franklin took a stab at his
peers and published the terms to go for
hurt at local pubs in the drinkers
dictionary here's what they said I've
got corns in my head oh go eat a pudding
bag Thomas you're one to talk Washington
you're as dizzy as a goose I'm shambled
my goodness Hamilton you've got a brass
eye today well the king was his cousin
clearly gentlemen you're all wasted
[Music]
open up your wallet you'd expect to find
ones tens 20s maybe even a hundo the
last thing you'd ever expect is a Tom
also known as a $2 bill here's why it
was 1862 the federal government had just
started printing its first paper money
the first and only denominations were
the $1 and $2 bills and keep in mind at
the time people were making about $15 a
month to pay using a $2 bill was a
status symbol only the wealthiest of
Americans could afford and a lot of the
time they used them for under-the-table
transactions like political bribes
prostitutes and gambling the Tom
ultimately got a bad rap and was deemed
unnecessary in 1966 the government took
a 10-year hiatus and stopped printing
those bad boys but in 1976 the
government gave them another try this
time classing them up a bit
issuing a special Bicentennial bill a
little too classy some would argue
people began hiding them away as
collectors items leading to less bills
in circulation which brings us to
present day though rare Tom's are still
being printed and there are over a
billion in circulation most people keep
them as keepsakes though there is a
subculture of $2 ambassadors who are set
on keeping the Tom alive by using them
every chance they get so the next time
you're paying with cash
go ahead use a Tom
[Music]
every day I turn off on to an old
country road it's about a mile from the
president's but you can see them and
then you get up to them and you stand
next to one and you go fan these things
are huge how many people on earth can
say they've got a collection of
presidents in their backyard that you
can see from space I know there's JFK I
have 43 presidents Ronald these guys
weigh approximately 14 to 21 thousand
pounds these things are huge huh
they've been here for about three years
and through time they're starting to
enjoy being out here they've got their
wildlife got a business
the weeds are growing up it's amazing
they amaze me these statues were once a
part of a outdoor park when the original
park had closed its doors I was asked to
destroy the president's and clean the
place off it hit me I said I'm not
destroying them I'm gonna figure out
something the feeling I get from them
it's it's overwhelming these guys they
still have strength today that they had
when they were alive and form in our
country they mean a lot to me I want to
bring them back to a museum where they
can be enjoyed by everybody
[Music]
in southern Pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the American Civil War this is
a story about that place it's also a
story about cats thousands and thousands
of little cats this is Rebecca
hi I'm Rebecca and this is her twin
sister Ruth hi I'm Ruth and we run a
museum of dioramas that are made with a
hand made at Civil War cats Civil War
cats the combination of a childhood love
for clay cats and a strong fascination
with the American Civil War it started
out as a hobby that we just did as kids
putzing around in our bedrooms that bit
of child's play led to a full-fledged
museum which opened in 2013
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale 1/8 of an inch equals one foot in
cat feet and so each one of our soldiers
represents one soldier who would have
been on the field will calculate the
numbers that would have been left in the
regiment and we'll fill it in with that
many cats soldiers so for example lower
on top we're going to eventually have
about 5,000 soldiers on it typically one
like the angle we figure took us about
four and a half years the Little Round
Top diorama we figure is more of a five
or six year diorama we really just want
to make the Civil War more approachable
I guess for people so they can relate to
the history and have more of a
connection with the men and the women
involved now that the word of this cat
museums out all the people who love cats
come in and now not only are they seeing
our dioramas are falling in love with
the five and a half thousand little
furry smiles smiling at them but they're
also learning the stories and suddenly
they have an appreciation of Gettysburg
and the history just because they came
to see the cats
[Music]
this is the northern bald eagle an
iconic bird that we almost lost for good
only a few decades ago northern Bald
Eagles are the larger of the two
subspecies of the bald eagle their
wingspan can reach over seven feet they
are powerful fliers that soar through
the air reaching over 40 miles per hour
when gliding they're excellent predators
attacking from above with their long and
sharp talons by the 1960s
their population was decimated with less
than 1000 left in the wild chemicals
from pesticides traveled up the food
chain rendering these top predators
sterile or unable to lay healthy eggs
thankfully after massive regulations
were put in place they have made a near
full recovery today loss of suitable
habitat is still a threat as they are
very sensitive to human activity this is
the northern bald eagle
[Music]